the road to the Super Bowl continues
this weekend the Jaguars are in Kansas
Kansas City tomorrow looking to pull off
another miracle then the Eagles play
host to their division Rivals the Giants
but all eyes will be on the rematch
between the Bengals and the bills Sunday
on CBS after Demar Hamlin collapse on
the field in their week 17 game the
Cowboys and the 49ers will renew their
playoff rivalry Sunday evening NFL on
CBS lead reporter one of the best in the
business Tracy Wilson joins us right now
Tracy good morning how you doing
good morning Nate how are you I'm good
thank you for joining us now there is
this rematch that everybody will be
watching the Bengals the bills now this
comes weeks after Demar Hamlin collapsed
on the field what are you hear from the
players about their approach and what
they're looking forward to in this game
well certainly needed has been an
emotional few weeks for for everyone
specifically for
the last two weeks so I've kind of seen
their progression and once they saw
Demar Hamlin on the road to recovery
once they saw him back in Buffalo in
person last Saturday at that walk
through there was a big sigh of relief I
think a lot of that emotional toll
that's been wearing on them has somewhat
eased and they were able to get back to
normal it wasn't the best game for them
against Miami last week but certainly
they feel like they're just playing
football now Demar Hamlin just on the
road to recovery but I can tell you if
he shows up at this game it is going to
be electric and there will be emotions
flowing in that stadium for sure
so no word yet on whether or not he's
going to actually be there
that is true no word yet there was a lot
of talk last week when we were there
whether he would show up he did watch
from his home but I was told that he has
been in the facility every day with the
team not in meetings yet just getting
back to a little bit of normalcy for
himself so we will all be waiting to see
if Demar Hamlin walks out of that tunnel
or is in a box and we see him on the
Jumbotron on Sunday
yeah we'll see Sunday night's uh game
the late game is Cowboys 49ers Dak
Prescott of the Cowboys star quarterback
there a veteran and then you've got a
rookie on the 49ers uh goes by the
nickname of Mr Irrelevant you're gonna
have to explain that one to me we're
talking Brock Purdy what are we looking
for
well Tony I'll tell you Mr Irrelevant
because he was the last pick in the
draft and what an unbelievable job he
has done for San Francisco now San
Francisco has so many weapons
surrounding them a lot of help to
provide this young rookie quarterback on
their offense specifically and then
their defense is one of the best in the
NFL but this will be a challenge for him
going against this defense of the
Cowboys led by Micah Parsons and the
pressure that he brings it is one of the
most anticipated games of the weekend
for a reason Dak Prescott as you know
Dallas and America's team well certainly
he he's coming off one of his best games
I think of his career if he can do that
go out there in San Francisco and play
without making mistakes utilizing his
legs they could pull off this upset
against the Niners
Tracy the the East Coast Fans are all
about the Giants versus the Eagles uh
that Turnpike series what can you tell
us what needs to happen Giants have lost
to what what do they need to do
well Michelle Giants have not lost in
Philadelphia since
2013. so that says a lot it is a very
hostile environment down in Philly as
they say the buses roll in and you don't
know what's going to be thrown at those
buses but I can tell you the Giants are
playing with a lot of confidence you
have two coaches right now and Nick
siriani and Brian dabal who I believe
should be in the coach of the year
conversation Daniel Jones playing with a
lot of confidence but certainly going to
be a huge Challenge on the road which
against a Philadelphia Eagles team that
is extremely balanced and Magellan hurts
quarterback who is coming off a little
bit of rest a shoulder injury and says
he is ready to go
Tracy Wolfson you are one of the best in
the business we appreciate you looking
forward to you on the sideline as usual
and maybe even the Jags pulling off an
upset in Kansas City
um all right we appreciate you thank you
so much you can catch me in the NFL
today crew this Sunday at 2 p.m Eastern
leading into CBS sports's coverage of
the Bengals Bills game on CBS and
Paramount plus big weekend of football